[Music]
well i saw people say thank god they
lost luna now we got three more years of
jk news they didn't say that and that's
right it's really fun
that's cool who's the best song okay
here we go welcome back to careful boys
where we are indeed very careful boys
you're super careful
so today we wanted to talk about i mean
dude
you know there's been a humbling moment
that has happened lately
um for a lot of us
oh no
um but you were planning on pivoting
like like out of
dance like early as you were you were
talking about that with us and like you
were like moving like in that direction
now you're going back into dance it
would you say that like or like how has
that transition been for you and and
what's um
weird about it for you and what how do
you process like everything that's going
on
wow that's a loaded question um
let's let's maybe give some context on
why i even thought about like kind of
like yeah yeah
i'm a little too aware because i was
yeah yeah because we were like talking
like well what's the boil down question
well i think i think one of the things
was adding anthony's like i'm like
39 every time i dance my phone's [ __ ]
my bones cracking and [ __ ] 36.
you got like two more years these young
cats like doing the moves that only he
dreams he could do so he's like oh [ __ ]
vigorous tick-tockers he can't save the
rec center with his body okay so
[Laughter]
okay so uh unlike uh silent mike's point
of view so dance is like also a sport
right
that's okay yeah which means that you
know [ __ ] you son
we are also like in essence like
athletes but i think that there's a
downside to that right it's just like
watching you can see uh just like in the
nba right once the older players that
they might have experience
but they might not necessarily have the
same physicality or the ability or or
even just just that youth to be able to
continue at the same pace like right now
right exactly like even like the older
you get the more you have to warm up or
the more you have to cool down and
stretch or like the more you're sore the
next day right and both in body and
spirit too totally because a young
basketball player like his the will of
lineup winner championship is also there
yeah steph so has that yeah versus if
you have like i don't know two kids that
are 13 you might be like this is to pay
for their college or seven kids like
lebron yeah yeah
but yeah that is a huge thing too
because like if you're um if you just
got opportunities in your career for
like the first couple years you're
really hyped but if you've been doing
similar opportunities for like let's say
like 13 years
you're desensitized to those
opportunities you're not thinking
yourself every day like oh my god i'm so
grateful i can dance you're thinking to
yourself like oh snap like how much time
do i have left you know so i think um
with the pandemic we also went through a
lot of like hard ships of the business
you guys already know like we closed the
studios we had to pivot in so many
different ways i stopped almost all my
work in china because like country
relations and politics kind of play and
like we can't go there without like
[ __ ] uh uh formal visas and
invitations from the government how big
of your guys's income would you say was
like from overseas
i mean that doesn't have to be dollar
amount but like percentage-wise or
something yeah it's hard to say you guys
because i think that there's so many
elements to answer that question for the
individuals and the group but let's say
for myself
i would i would honestly say like
honest at least fifty percent minimum
and i think that's reflective you guys
know too that's reflective of also my
time right yeah for sure like most of my
time even when i was like like i've been
doing jk news since you guys started but
i was only here whenever i had a pocket
until i really heard very much
i was here when you know you weren't
here before you you weren't here he was
here whenever we couldn't find another
guest yet that's true yeah you were here
when we wanted someone to play a gay guy
he was here
you're here for what 12 hours before me
i was here for like [ __ ] 2700 hours
and that's when the [ __ ] started going
down and everybody started quitting and
so they had because i think the energy
was well because of me
and then when i came on things started
picking up and there's like regular the
vibes cool yeah another fusion more than
ever yeah that's crazy dancers brought
all the sentiment in a lot of logic
practicalities alien to the audience and
made people worse otherwise everybody
would have thought this was just a
republican group that sports trump
another dancer you know that's not no i
think that's like really cool and i
think that you were really thankful for
what we're doing now the dancers are
here that people throwing pain on the
car they're like why did you leave it to
the dancers
i mean you know it's crazy you deserve
it you made us all lose on luna 50 of
your income
gonzos
i made you lose yeah that's a huge thing
i told you to cash out don't even start
on omg with these guys you know i mean
two two fails right let's see i can't
believe we're still friends omg omg was
the first time
the first part of the bear market in the
bull market the first one that went that
multiply [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i couldn't have got to a million if not
for omg thank [ __ ] for that but also
[ __ ] omg
thank god i dumped that piece of [ __ ]
it's like a doll or something now dude
it's like no it's like no it's like two
whatever the [ __ ] it is it's still more
valuable still more valuable than boba
which is it's actual use case boba yeah
but nobody's even heard of it it's a
slayer to use case nobody [ __ ] even
knows about that because they diluted
the shares for all the people who are
holding it omg up completely
a complete trader took a piece of [ __ ]
is still trading better than boba hey
[ __ ] you bobatards you guys are honestly
the dumbest [ __ ]
maybe ever i can't believe you're still
holding that piece of [ __ ] i i turned i
turned eighteen thousand dollars into a
[ __ ] 1.2 million dollars you guys
were all holding bags of [ __ ] during the
whole bear market i still cashed out
more than you pulling bags of [ __ ]
holding bags of [ __ ] [ __ ] leaking out
of the bottom breaking with [ __ ]
following you guys wanted to take the
[ __ ] home you stupid [ __ ] i want to see
a movie that's like wolf of wall street
just with steve crypto style
i just you know i'm not [ __ ] going
anywhere bro i haven't even i barely put
20 grand into crypto i've done 735 and
i'm 1.2 mil and dude i'm sitting here
with six figgies
in the bottom of the bear [ __ ] watch
what i do next if you don't wanna hit
two i will and guess what i'll write it
to [ __ ] zero
that's what i do [ __ ]
and i'm following with you
we're doing it again and guess what
we're not cashing out again better
that's the moment and i'm writing this
to 0.
so back to anthony anthony
i no longer remember pandemic happened
50 of your income's gone out the window
you're aging man
can't dance like the new geriatric human
being
i really like that word mm-hmm yeah he
said a lot today it's very good and and
uh you know the the
the cove pandemic just kind of brought
on a lot of like business problems and
like that's always been a lot of the
trade-off right like to try and be like
as
the best version of your artist and
creative self as possible you know what
i mean like literally just
choreographing or dancing whatever but
then still also having to have the right
type of mindset or like focus and
attention in like the business side and
things that we're not doing so well
right like handling of landlords while
closing this spot you know working
through i don't even want to go into the
[ __ ] up details of it but um or on the
other side like trying to build a noodle
company and pivot because like dance was
cut out you know what i mean so many
other elements came into play and i got
also really lucky with certain things
right i got to be able to like anchor
myself into like this place which is
like totally like a second home and a
family to me as well you know and like
being able to be present and available
for jk all the time while also starting
up things like season two of the kindest
podcast where like we're hosting and
producing it out of my own home so i'm
putting so much of my like personal self
into it i started having like
and that's crazy to think that i was
like a part of and became like one of
the the co-hosts of like this show plus
like the podcast
it's like
suddenly i started even seeing
opportunities for my own like future
that didn't necessarily have to anchor
itself in like dance
and i wanted to um one maybe listen to
the universe right like oh yeah the
universe is literally being like stop
[ __ ] dancing
and do all this other [ __ ] and handle
all this other [ __ ] but then two it was
also be a shoemaker sell noodle
shoemaker
shoemaker come on a talk show where
everyone shits on you every day i love
that the shoe is [ __ ] nike by the way
does a nike shoe get [ __ ] on my stick
look he's a cobbler at the end of it
with [ __ ] nails and a hammer to boil
it all down to being a cobbler ask me a
question let's let's talk about the
truth
it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] shining shoes and repairing
um so so uh yeah i think um that plus
and let's let's be real like we [ __ ]
like got super super into like luna and
crypto doing all this stuff too
and we're [ __ ] killing it we're
killing it
it's so difficult sickest run-up ever
ever so the worst run down ever
dude i i would have cashed out
and i was like are you gonna cash out
nope and i'm like well i'm not either
cause all of us wanted to go [ __ ] 10x
again the best part
is like we got a 2 000
right like because i was buying a five
or whatever
so we got two thousand percent and and
i'm like and my brother's like hey are
we gonna cash this out and i was like
we should need another 5x
you got two thousand percent bro what
the [ __ ] is your problem that's so funny
dude that's just you know what i mean
and so like
you can't that's the human part about it
right it's the same thing even though
it's [ __ ] in hindsight two thousand
percent why the [ __ ] did we not do xyz
because it's called greed there it is
there it is but when you're in it that
also you know like um well you do fake
logic too it's like dude that's what i'm
saying and the ratios we're killing
bitcoin so hard this whole time when
bitcoin was at 69 000 the all-time high
we were at [ __ ] forty dollars and
then we went to 119 so wait till bitcoin
gets back there and the ratios we're
going to be
and we were like all season hasn't hit
maturity yet
doesn't matter although i have to say
bitcoin dominance as an indicator was
pretty sick i just should have listened
to it like 30 going into the 30s it did
and it skidded into the 30s for seven
months
that's not good enough for you bro
come on
we're really just talking to ourselves
yeah
but
really that like um
you know that that
changes a lot of your perception on what
life maybe could be
so i think i started getting caught up
uh in allowing kind again like the
natural momentum in my head that i may
be constructed i'll be honest with you
of like that momentum of like oh maybe
this is kind of your time
to not focus so much on dance because
we're all millionaires so what's the
what's the [ __ ] point of doing this
we were millionaires for a very very
short period of time it's awesome
i am still on paper by the way don't you
forget that i am too technically because
of real estate but videos about me guys
if we could bring it back i would love
to not talk about that
so that kind of happened and uh
obviously everybody knows that the lunar
crash happened but more than even just
the crash like i also you know still
endured and had to like go through even
more
similar
crashes yeah if you will
uh
man will you guys cut a lot of corners
on the noodles
no it has nothing to do with the noodles
oh there's nothing to do the noodles are
doing good
okay that was a guess the noodles are
doing well and stuff like that you know
what i mean but yeah just just other
complications
like life complications life
complications with business and stuff
um and
the funny thing is when almost uh again
even with luna when everything is gone
and luna's like no longer the crypto in
general is kind of like all right cool
we don't really have that
and then the business stuff you know
what i mean is going really really tough
too and like things like i'm losing a
lot in different ways
you suddenly find yourself in this
really humble position
and then you think about what you
actually have what the [ __ ] are you
laughing at it's killing me dude i
[ __ ] hate this guy no
i just noticed something up there
continue nick is killing me sorry sorry
so you find yourself in this really
humble position where um you feel like
you kind of don't really have anything
else so you start thinking to yourself
what do i actually have
that like no one can take away from me
that i can like use right now that's
guaranteed that i i'm in control of
myself and the irony is that you know
it just falls right back to dance for
myself you know what i mean like no
matter what no matter where i'm at
and everything that i put into my my my
skill and my networks and my you know my
relationship building with people or
just the industry in general it's kind
of like
i guess i could just pick that back up
and go right back into it and like put
time and energy into it and really
you know not i'm i wouldn't say i was so
far out that it's like giving it a
second go by any means but rather just
revitalizing the the the energy and the
motivation to do it um
like even during the height of crypto
stuff you were still i think if i were
to be honest with it though i think a
lot you know when you get into a flow of
doing something for so long yeah some
things become maintenance right
i feel like a lot of energy felt like
maintenance okay and i think that's also
yeah towards that and that's probably
also why for at least my like close fans
who like really follow me you'll realize
that like i even stopped posting on
social media because i just lost the
that uh expressive kind of element to
like what i wanted to share with my
craft and stuff like that and not lost
it like it's all gone and like
everything is depressing or anything it
was just one of those moments where i
was like i'm not in this right now and i
need to like listen to kind of that
intuition and vibe out otherwise that
maintenance of kind of
thing will hold on to me and i'm just
i'm just going through the motions you
wanted to shed it yeah did you ever um
dance just for the fun of it anymore
because if you know how when something
becomes a profession you don't even
touch it anymore you know what's crazy
it was actually
two days ago
on wednesday that i for the first time
uh i had charlie come over my spot and i
was like hey man i just want to have a
creative session and i want to
choreograph to a song that is not work
related it's not for the youtube channel
you had him come over for that reason or
he came over and then it's been that i
haven't come up for that reason that's
dope you're just like let's have a
session we used to do it all the time
literally every day when we were living
in orange county we go to quest learning
center which is in artesia
and like back in the day we would show
up in the morning but hey what time
you're gonna get there boom that's it
every day we'd show up
smoke bowl eat some food and then we
would just go into session it was always
freestyles in the morning and then we
would create and like that was just the
flow and that was honestly one of my
happiest times in my entire dance
journey because it was um also we
weren't like hella known or successful
by any means so it was very easy
oh actually actually charles had [ __ ]
won abdc but i wasn't at all in that
limelight i had not gone on a tv show so
it was just really easy for us to just
do it for the fun
but on this past wednesday it was the
first time i had choreographed or tried
to choreograph for myself and that's the
hardest part right you give me an
assignment it's easy it's like um the
confines when's it due what's the song
how many artists uh what's the style
what are you looking for during the hook
is it a catchy move give it this
influence wear this blah blah
give me these the parameters and the
assignments give me a thousand details
and it's just it's like an escape room
it's just finding out what makes sense
considering all those things give me a
blank canvas when i'm not practiced
and you're just chopping at yourself the
whole [ __ ] time which is also um
yourself you hate everything second
guessing all your so you're just
standing there and going like [ __ ] you
can't pop and long you can't lock it
worse than that get a whole eight count
or two eight counts in do it and then
throw the whole thing away oh man and
then and that's why i got into golf i
could relate to that because even like
when we were writing skits when you were
trying to write something like okay like
writing parodies are easy right okay
this is what everyone likes or this
style or whatever well that was a hitter
so let's do another one just like that
that's easy because it's almost it
removes the burden and responsibility of
trying to express your true self but
then when you're like okay cool now it's
time to write for myself this represents
the inside of me all of a sudden it's
like really like vulnerable and then you
do have a oh and it's going in a way
that's not really like me anymore you
cut that off and you rip that paper so i
i relate to it and nick was even just
talking about this too where it's like
same thing with like fighting right when
you're young you're just like i'm a
[ __ ] fight yeah yeah you don't really
think about munching but sometimes
that's the kind of like the attitude
that you need to get in there just that
like that naivety actually is helpful
that child like wonder you know what i
mean when you [ __ ] become a geriatric
[ __ ] adult
that's not necessarily in practice or in
flow all the time you come back to
something and you got all these dumbass
adult thoughts
you know what i mean it's so [ __ ]
just like what what about this like how
do i do this how do i finish it with
this ears worries and doubts what about
my time like you know when am i supposed
to handle this other responsibility am i
[ __ ] [ __ ] my time up right now
because blah blah how are people gonna
feel about what i've done because i
haven't done anything in a long time you
started doing these dumb ass adult
things as a creative and it blocks you
like crazy you know um i had a great
session even though nothing got finished
but i think it's it's kind of like
working out right just because you have
a bad workout doesn't mean that was bad
for you yeah sometimes you just got to
do it right so i feel like that's kind
of where i'm at and and that's
ironically part of the joy but you have
a you feel like a muscle memory right
like it's like
obviously because you you can get back
to your mean right get back to your
basics which is really cool totally like
obviously like you know obviously yeah
you were away from it for a while but
then you snapped back into it and like
but you said i never really left yeah i
think i was like kind of checking out
yeah it's different you probably needed
it but it was very mental like because i
still had to dance every week
i just wasn't doing it for me i did it
like i
missed it's almost embarrassing to say
and i don't know how many people you
know who were inspired by the dance
journey if they heard this they'd be
like what the [ __ ] but it's like i
haven't gotten up to session out of the
passion and joy and love for dance for
myself music's just sick as [ __ ] and i'm
just like yo let me [ __ ] get up and
vibe i haven't done that
in months because like i don't feel it
but i don't think to myself that's a
sadness i just feel like i'm in a
different place in my life and dance
is a different i have a different
relationship with it i mean it's like
it's like professional chefs i'll
oftentimes just go home and eat a bowl
of rice because they're cooking all day
you know when it becomes your profession
and you do it for over a decade your
approach to it is completely different
than when you're sessioning at the park
with your friends yeah and i think one
of the hardest things to like admit to
yourself too especially on something
that has like defined you right both in
career and image so many people like
associate every aspect of that with you
right
to
admit to yourself like hey i love this
but right now i'm not in love with it
you know what i mean that's so difficult
because it's so
so attached to everything that is your
core being or at least like what
you've built or society's helped you
build and that perception so um but i
can at least acknowledge and accept that
now and i think that journey is also
part of the maturity and the
relationship is exactly what it is a
relationship it's not it's gonna be
perfect
and uh i i think right now
if anything part of the journey is
figuring out how to fall back in love
with it you know what i mean i can't i
can't honestly again i don't have
i'm not checked out now and i don't i've
never like fully left the game at all
i've always been in the game
but now it's a matter of trying to like
find my way back for the reasons that
are more on my own terms and i think
that's also cool too
because i think one of the things that
was like [ __ ] me up also
is you go with the flow of [ __ ] right
and one of the flows in in our life
especially the way that we have to do
our hustle and bustle is things like
social media so once social media
changed like things like tick tock and
the way that even dance was perceived
suddenly even we myself and kids we got
into a flow we're like cool let's start
doing these short form tick tocks and
blah blah
maybe we'll do these challenges because
that's where the world's going blah blah
and suddenly you find yourself like
weeks later in this place where you're
like
uh the [ __ ] am i doing you know it's not
wrong there's nothing wrong with that
mad respect to everybody plays that game
we're just in a different time of life
right it's like the og's looking at us
when we first started youtube when
youtube started it they're looking at us
like the [ __ ] dude you guys aren't the
truth
you know what i mean but it's just yo i
don't know we were just using the
platform that was given to our
generation you know and the same thing
is happening now but
now because like
i was kind of checked out now i'm
checking back in
i feel like as a more grown adult with
all the problems of like having the
adult thoughts i also have the pros of
being able to come in maybe i'm more on
my own terms the way i like it the way i
want to do it the music i want to do it
too and whether success comes or not
from that in the same way did in the
past like [ __ ] all like it really
doesn't matter because you start to
realize the things that you want to
value in your life you're going to
protect that everything else is just
noise anyway right like we can never
control where it's going we can only
control like how we're doing it is all
seems like a fresh start in a weird way
how did that what did dancers do when
they [ __ ] agree they go like this
right they go like this
this is props thank you this means like
uh props alive with that
what do dancers do when they cut corners
on the noodles
couldn't let them have
it couldn't let him wrap it up oh you
guys gave that one
[Music]
you